yeah jiendo bruh and here's some stuff
good morning my rather good afternoon my
name is Steph and today I'll be talking
about taking some unclean data from
different sources and trying to wrap it
up into something that's relatively
clean and correct so that software
engineers and other data scientists can
use it but before I begin I would like
to introduce myself a bit first so you
have some kind of idea of where I'm
coming from and what kind of work I do
I'm a computational linguist by
education and also in my current role I
do cavitational linguistics at my
current job where we build chat BOTS and
a lot of the work that I do is
extracting text data from different
sources such as newspapers or Wikipedia
or websites and trying to make it into
something that's consumable by machine
learning models and I'd also like to
talk a bit about the place where I had
kind of my roots in programming it's the
recurse Center and it's a really special
place because you can get to meet other
programmers with the same or similar
interests as you and if you are working
on something or want to work on
something I'd never had the time the
recurse Center in New York City is a
great place to be and to meet other
people it's a free program so hopefully
everyone or anyone who wants to can
attend and personally it was
transformative not just for my career
but also for my life so let's continue
throughout the conference you'll
probably hear or see these three letters
ETL this talk is meant to be a gentle
introduction to cleaning data and what
entails or what like ETL means and
entails and so on first I'll begin with
EEGs it's sorry
it stands for extracting and it more or
less means getting data from wherever
with whatever format so wherever could
be a website or your colleague from
accounting or maybe some CSV file that
you found on github and the format's
could be again like an HTML page or an
excel sheet or yeah it could be anything
that's resembles some sort of data that
you may need the next letter in ETL is T
and that means transform it means
transforming you transforming data to
the structure you want it to be it it's
where most of the work actually happens
and it's where most of the blood sweat
and tears will come out and load is
loading data into some database or
warehouse for access later or for like
updating so today I'll talk about some
restaurant data that I was playing
around with I only had two requirements
one was that the restaurant should be
vegan vegetarian or vegetarian friendly
and that they're located in Poland so
two requirements pretty simple right
like maybe you could do it in like three
hours
no probably took me closer to 13 or even
13 it's pretty rough and I got data from
three different sources first is this
website called Vega mapa de piel and
it's it's a website that has a bunch of
these things for different venues and
restaurants that have veg friendly food
the Foursquare API it's where I was
hoping to get like ratings and other
data from that I could enrich the data
that I got from Vega mapa and finally a
CSV containing data on poland's bigger
cities because i wanted to have I wanted
to be able
to normalize the locations as well and I
will talk about a bit about this more
later and I use different tools for the
different sources so for scraping Vega
mapa I used selenium and some of you may
wonder why did I not use beautifulsoup
why do I have to use selenium why do you
have to be so extra and use selenium the
answer is because Vega mapa renders the
page with JavaScript so you cannot
scrape it with a beautiful soup you have
to actually interact with the browser to
be able to get the different restaurant
listings so a beautiful soup is great if
your website is static and I also use a
popular Python package requests it just
to send API requests to Foursquare and
be able to like process JSON because
requests also has a very handy method
called JSON which you can call on the
response and it actually loads the JSON
for you and sorry and I also use pickle
to serialize responses from Foursquare
because Foursquare has rate limits and I
kept hitting them like pretty quickly so
and what I later learned was that I
should probably serialize the responses
that I already got 200 status codes from
and just only process requests that have
that wouldn't have been processed
because I hit my quota
and finally pandas to read the CSV file
so scraping begum abroad at PL is pretty
straightforward there's a lot of
boilerplate boilerplate code just
because of that's how selenium works I
load up a browser
I get the web page and I wait until this
class name
GM style appears and I'm waiting for
this to appear because that's
essentially the map where all of the
different listings for restaurants are
like pinned to and where I get my data
from and if it's not there I wouldn't be
able to get this text data so I just
have this delay until this element shows
up and I also directly just extracted
the text from the elements by the CSS
selector so the data that comes out of
this looks something like this
it's each each item in the list
represents our restaurant listing so as
you can see it's not really very clean
you have the restaurant name the street
name the area what kind of a category
the category of the restaurant and this
word gosh they're all discussed other
and I'll talk a bit more about how I can
eat this data later on reading CSV data
is relatively straightforward and took
me maybe like two minutes because it
really is just two lines are you read
the CSV file and I was lucky enough that
the Poland city's data was relatively
clean and yeah this is how it looks what
I wanted from this data was the city and
which region or province
it belonged to because in the Vega mapa
data some of the locations had the
provinces and some didn't and what I was
concerned with was what if you had two
places two cities with the same name but
were in different provinces like how
would you resolve this conflict then so
this is why I needed the the this data
finally I was getting Foursquare d'etat
with with requests and as I previously
mentioned there was a rate limit and I
used picol to store the response objects
that had a status code of 200 into my
disk so that I could read it later when
I was actually doing the entire batch
and getting the responses content so
this is an abridged version of like what
I did with the requests data from
Foursquare API I already knew the
category ID because when I was looking
through the Foursquare API I found out
that they had a slash categories
endpoint where all of the categories
possible that was that existed in
Foursquare was listed including its ID
so if you had this ID and you've had the
cities that you wanted to like query
against like find these restaurants or
venues you could actually get a very
comprehensive list and this is how the
response looks like it's a very huge
JSON response so I just I'm just
displaying the ones that I thought was
particularly interesting to me which is
rating the location and the name yeah
and the next step is transforming this
data the and how I would normalize this
different data sources into a target
format so it's really important to have
a target format in mind ideally you
should know exactly how it looks like
but we know that that's probably hardly
ever the case so yeah having a rough
idea would be very useful and cleaning
data is often necessary before it can be
transformed so nowadays the the lines
between cleaning data and transforming
data is like blurred because usually
clean data then transform it or
sometimes you're cleaning data as you're
transforming the data as well
and I wanted to show us all a target
format or how I wanted a response object
to look like or rather the restaurants
data structure to look like so this is
the schema of the JSON object it's just
as it's simply a description of the
listing the properties I would want it
to have and what kind of data structure
it looks like so I wanted it to have a
name the street the city the province
the zip the category rating and pricing
tier so as I mentioned before cleaning
is where much of the work is performed
this is where a lot of manual work
actually happens and as a lot of
practitioners in the industry would like
like keep reiterating to me at least is
that your models will only ever be as
good as your data so you have to like do
you have to really put an effort into
cleaning into cleaning it and having
data that could be very easily
consumable by like a machine learning
API remodel so the first thing that you
should probably do is drop duplicates or
you could also do this in the last last
episode because perhaps while you're
cleaning the data duplicates may arise
strip whitespace so a problem I had when
I was scraping the Vega mapper website
was that for some reason it when I was
doing a merge on the city's CSV and the
Vega bappa data it would it was merging
on some cities on some cities perfectly
fine that I knew like existed in both
data sets like warszawa
for example but then when I checked the
the cities that were not supposedly
existent in the city's database
masha'allah appeared again so and the
reason for that was that there was a
white space at the end or a white space
the beginning and it's as a competition
in English like this is actually one of
the first things we do but you do it so
often and sometimes you just forget
about it um you should probably also
discard unnecessary data so for example
like this phrase scash tazza
is probably not important to me for the
for the data that I have because it just
means I think directions or how to get
there and it would it be so useful to me
in the data structure that I have so I
just dropped this
there was also inconsistency between the
data sets in the CSV file containing
data on Polish cities it listed Rishabha
as Warsaw while Viki map uses Java and
for services but both my update is
warszawa because every other city in the
Polish cities file used the Polish
orthographic representation so I thought
it just made sense null values so how do
we handle null values in the end it
depends on what you're using the data
for and what you're trying to achieve
but in in my case the force per API
venue endpoints spec describes ratings
for example from 0 through 10 but it
holds but they also said that not all
venues may have a rating so I decided to
default it 2-1 to represent that no one
has actually rated it because someone
could actually come to a venue and write
it 0 then and if I were defaulted to 0
it means that ok this bad restaurant
also it's me um has the same rating as a
restaurant that maybe no one seemed like
ever rated so I wanted to make this this
this distinction other places where null
values occurred where in categories so
if no one puts on a category I just put
no category and also for like cities and
states or addresses I just put unknown
or not found
so now that I was able to clean this
data relatively well I had to combine
these multiple sources into a single
data frame so that it's I can visualize
about like what's happening and maybe if
there's something I missed I can go back
and correct it so for the CSV file and
the script website data it is merged on
the cities column because that's where I
wanted it to be because this is the
column that both both data frames shared
or both data sources shared and also I
wanted the province to be corrected so
that's why I emerged it on the city
instead of city and province and this is
how it looks like after these after the
clean data from the second map our
website was merged with the city data
from from the CSV file with Polish
cities so this resulting dataset is then
merged with Foursquare data on named
City Street and province the reason why
it's more comprehensive than for example
the CSV file and the script website data
is because you could actually have
several restaurants with the same name
in the same city in same province so for
example maybe you have a chain called I
don't know a greenway for example like
in this example up here there's two
greenways right you would need the
street address to differentiate between
the two as well so this is how it looks
like when you merge them in with pandas
and this is how the resulting data
structure looks like so this is just a
small sample of the data that I that I
compiled good as you can see it's like
relatively clean
but until someone actually like sits
down or you like writes down a validator
for this data set we can't be sure that
it's a clean and be correct because
there's a difference between clean and
correct data because you could have
clean data but not correct or not
comprehensive data so for example like
if I did not fill the categories with no
category if I just serve them as na n or
sometimes before it was actually na n or
null so instead of having these two
different representations of
non-existent I just forced a category
for these these things hold no category
so again going back to the target format
then we had this is how it looks like so
I was actually able to achieve the
vision that I had for my restaurants
data set for loading the data you can
either just throw your data in to post
your sequel or MongoDB for the kind of
data I had which is that one restaurant
represented one document MongoDB
probably seems like an obvious choice
because there's no relationship between
the two but PostgreSQL also has support
for Jason today as well so you can
actually store your JSON files into a
postcard post your SQL and access the
attribute or the keys the key value
pairs on your JSON object with
PostgreSQL Jason and you also have the
benefits of the relational relational
database as well if you ever decide to I
don't know like have some sort of
relations between your data once you've
gotten more familiar and comfortable
with extract extraction transformation
and loading you can use different
toolkits to help you with
let's say streamlining your workload and
your pipeline you can use bonobo it has
a very easy to use and easily
understandable API and so does petal or
PTL PTL is more as better documented
than bonobo but I think maybe all of you
should check out both of them and decide
for yourself which one you like better
thanks for coming and yeah if you have
any questions do let me know okay so the
question was how did I validate data
that I already cleaned and have on my
data source or like the clean data that
I have as a result so what I used is a
JSON schema validator and there's
several Python packages for that and I
just ran my JSON objects through this
JSON schema validator against the JSON
schema that I myself um described ah
[Music]
[Music]
okay so the question actually was how do
I know that the data that I got the Hat
is a real representation of a real place
in the real world correct
I don't in the end I just have to trust
this website and hope that it's on in
the end it's also like my own judgment
whether this website is reputable or not
and that's part of the work that you
have to do as well when you're
extracting data it's researching if
the data they're actually producing is
legitimate yeah yet so there was no
rating and I just wanted to represent it
as minus one so if I have if I okay okay
so the question was if I had done any
further data exploration or analysis on
geospatial data that I have and the
answer is though I tried but the from my
cursory google search a lot of the
geospatial data is behind a paywall
and it's pretty expensive yeah so you
mean I put them into a Google map oh no
I haven't tried that yet any other all
right I think we can finish with this
thank you again and run applause
[Applause]